there's a reason that we go with the
latest fashion trend there's a reason
that politicians cater to us there's a
reason that we make 80 percent of
consumers buying decisions there's a
reason we don't make good life decisions
in general think about this guy all we
had to do was wait till 22 to 25 be a
virgin we could go get like a Saudi
billionaire millionaire I mean and stay
in shape right and you got to be like
semi-cute but like honestly without with
how bad the Western women are that's all
we had to do yet most women will think
only fans before they think of that
strategy what does that say about
women's decision making when one out of
25 of us under the age of 35 are on only
fans